well we showed a clip from wreck-it
Ralph - Ralph breaks the internet and
was Ralph and vanellope visiting a
website that is oh my disney.com
it's a fan of Disney fan site it's a
real site and we personified it so it's
a lot like d23 it's like going to
displays for all the fans are the little
users and vanellope
meets the Disney Princesses and it's a
great theme with Sarah Silverman you
know and all the voices of well we have
most of the Disney princess voices you
know most of those that are still with
us and it's a very funny scene you know
it's about Penelope kind of embracing
her princessness she goes in initially
thinking yeah what's with these
princesses and then realizes oh man
they're really cool these are cool women
I like them I like what they're about
and because vanellope is a princess
technically from the first film you know
she she calls herself she's running it
as a constitutional democracy but she is
actually a princess so her relationship
to these princesses sort of grows over
the course of the scene for the d23 Expo
we had nine princesses come on to the
stage the voices of I mean we had Moana
you had bocahantas Dallas goes on and on
Ariel yeah they're all they're all
together I think for the first time ever
yeah and yeah and then Sarah Silverman
who is the newest princess as vanellope
ornated yeah
today she was Sarah was Court and
vanellope von schweetz was was brought
into the pantheon of Disney Princesses
today couldn't be prouder it's so good
and just from the table read - each time
we record that's what makes these movie
so great it's like every time they're
always working on the story making it
better fixing it tweaking it changing it
you know as we go on and on I'm just
it's this people so good and very
excited about it we were really excited
that Disney was game for a scene like
that
with all the princesses and you know
that's kind of something that I like
about Disney is they they change at the
time so you know and that's important to
do to let yourself be changed by new
information this is my first be 23 um
last to be 23 I remember Twain was here
and I remember watching it at home like
on YouTube on my phone and screaming at
my phone and finally you know two years
is fast and everyone really knows and
the response has just been so fantastic
for each one of the Disney Princesses
and to also include Sarah Silverman in
this it's so precious to know that you
know I felt that same excitement to be
part of this amazing group of women and
now we haven't yet another princess to
add to the mix it was fantastic okay so
I already know Disney fans are y'all are
crazy but it was insane when everyone
was up there oh my gosh the response was
amazing
I mean versus people's childhood I know
that I saw my own childhood on that
stage this afternoon and everyone was
just so happy so proud to see these
Disney characters represented once again
in another film it means so much to me
Moana was is such a strong character she
was beautiful and sent it out and there
was something to learn from each of the
Disney Princesses I think they've
certainly changed over time and the ones
that they have been quick that have been
created more is vastly different from
the rest and they all have their
similarities and differences but they're
all kind they're always wonderful and
they all have something to add to the
world so I'm really happy but you know
this is unbelievable it's unprecedented
it's never been done before you know
nine of us all together you know and the
demographic from Anika and well Nike
Ali's the youngest to me the oldest and
it's really kind of wonderful
wreckit-ralph movie okay guys this next
number two movie is pretty incredible
and the princesses are all brought
together on this and it's sheer genius I
actually got really emotional today I
was just going to crazy moving on when I
walked out there and then I saw the
response and heard the response if L
like you know
this is a real blessing you know at this
point in my career you know in my life
you know and it's a great thing to be a
part of it it's sort of a historic thing
because we've never had all the
princesses on stage at one time so
people were extraordinarily thrilled
about that and the princesses are now
going to be seen I think in a different
way than we're used to seeing them we
get to see them let their hair down no
pun intended and so it's going to be
something special and I've had people
say to me like like you know people
always call you Pocahontas you know I
mean don't bother you sometimes I'm like
no it's kind of like getting be Santa
Claus your whole life I mean who could
have a problem with that I have you know
from little ones with those really big
eyes you just you just are just you know
full of you with the magic and you get
to be magic and then now you know that
there's a generation that's grown up and
and I still get to see that it's an
historical day I'm just meeting a lot of
these girls for the very first time and
just to all be together in one room and
sort of have this history going on we go
over the courses I've been with the
company 32 years and we go all the way
to Milano who's sweet 16 it was just
it's really an amazing day an amazing
day to get to know everybody had so much
fun we just saw the clip for the very
first time we're watching it from
backstage and we were cracking up you
know when we record we're by ourselves
when we record so you don't really know
what the other reads are going to be and
the interpretations of the lines and
stuff like that so it was really fun to
get to see it all nish together is
hysterical but that's all because of
John Lasseter and the team I mean just
brilliant hysterical amazing so we're
honored it was really exciting for all
of us because we have all worked on this
movie already but we haven't been
together we all record separately and
some of us know each other and some of
us didn't so it was really special to be
all together and I loved it the crowd
was so excited that it just
delay the departure lake we're all in
the same world in this movie which is
really cool and such a great idea
so it was really nice to see that
everybody loved it I loved it too is our
first time seeing it
we stood backstage and watched it on the
monitor from backstage so it's really
cool I mean I think it's just yeah it's
pretty pretty cool to see all of us like
in the same room at the same time and
sort of onstage together United as one
troupe of princesses it's never lost on
you the just tremendous impact that your
life sort of has because you've had the
pleasure and privilege of being a part
of the Disney lineage I mean that's it's
it's an experience that I will
definitely carry for the rest of my life
and I mean Kristen Bell and I were kind
of looking at each other like are we to
be here doing this and 15 20 years
together standing backstage like hoping
that people are excited like still
remember who we are
no but it's pretty it's pretty
incredible when you see the you know
just the incredible women that were that
we were lucky enough to be in the
company of up there I've been doing it
for so long it's really remarkable I'm
here with a select group of princesses
Disney Princesses which I can't I still
can't believe that I am one or the voice
of one and so yeah we we make a little
cameo in the movie there's a little fun
sequence with all the big crazy birds
and there are the princesses because
when you see them individually in their
own film you kind of they seem sane and
then when you see them all together
talking and telling their stories is
they're bonkers